mmm
it started as legend one of the greatest
of all
one of the oldest of all
but every legend has a secret they have
been here forever
in the shadows to protect Earth from
what was destined to arrive
a thousand years we've kept it hidden
[Music]
the secret history of transformers
[Music]
it started as a legend one of the
greatest of all years we've kept it
hidden to protect Earth from what is
destined to arrive Optimus Prime you
destroyed your home you seek Redemption
I knew
[Music]
your daughter what would you say to her
brush your teeth work hard stay away
from any boy in a band especially a
drummer these are troubled times without
leaders chaos reigns
two worlds colliding
you're all that stand in its way
and now the greatest mission of them all
to turn the tide of human history
[Applause]
the imminent destruction of everything
we know and love begins
I'm not leaving you
when all seems lost a few brave souls
[Music]
save everything we've ever known the
operation is over when I keep it up my
prime okay
on the state
and I once I said
[Music]
for my world to live
yours must die
you
[Music]
you